learn how to use the mernstack by
creating a bookstore application the
mernstack is a powerful blend of mongodb
a nosql database express.js a web
framework react.js a UI building
JavaScript library and node.js a
server-side JavaScript environment
together they provide a cohesive
framework for building efficient
responsive web applications Mohammed
taheri is a full stack developer and he
will teach you quickly and simply how to
build with the myrn stack hello
everybody so what is the plan we are
going to create a basic bookstore
project we use Mana Stacks so we will
have mongodb express.js react and Dot JS
just some little tips before I start you
must know JavaScript and basic react for
this tutorial I try to explain
everything as simple as possible all
quotes are available on my GitHub you
can find the link on video description
what do you need for this tutorial first
you need to have node.js in Instagram
your computer then you need a code
editor and a browser I use vs code and
chrome but you can use anything you want
no let's go and start coding first
create a new folder with name of
bookestore man stack then open it in
VSCO
here create two separate folders for
backend and front-end projects also I
created that git ignore file and also a
readme.md file for the GitHub repo you
can ignore this now let's initialize our
project make sure that you are on the
backends folder and type CD backend to
go to backend folder then type npm initi
Y and press enter this command will add
a package that Json to our project
and inside of this package.json file
let's add a new line with the type of
module this line will allows us to use
ecmascript syntax which is import
keyword and Export keyword Also let's
add two packets to our project
express.js and not more so let's type
npmi Express node mod we use express as
our framework and also we use notebook
for restarting server automatically
unchanged now let's add to a scripts to
a script section A start will run the
project with node.js environment and
then we learn the project with nodemon
and we use this command in development
now let's create a new file with name of
index.js this file will be the starter
of our project we need express.js
framework so let's add it here then
Define a new variable for it
then let's make it listen to a port it
is better solution to separate your
codes to different files and folders so
for the port I want to create another
file with name of config.js and I will
Define my port in this file a better way
to saving this port variable is that n
file but I don't want to add it to this
project so let's use this config.js for
this tutorial then you need to import
the supporting index.js file and use it
we need a function for listening to this
port let's create after listen function
and use our port in it after port we can
pass a callback function to app.listen
and let's have a single console.log with
a message to be sure that everything is
okay now let's run our project using
Esco terminal type npm brand div this
command will start the server on our
selected Port no in console if you see
this message it means that our server is
running and we don't have any problem
now we have a basic server This Server
language is Javascript it uses
express.js as a backend framework and
you can run this server on any machine
with node.js environment let's run it
and see the result first I check my
node.js environment with this command
node.v this command must give you the
version of installed node.js then I use
npm from Dev to run my server using
notepad well we see the success message
and it's good now let's open our browser
and check the result on server Port
which is 5555 so we need to go to local
hotspot 55555 and this message shows
cannot get a slash let's open developer
tools and go to network section here you
can see network requests I refresh my
page you can see a request to localhost
and it has a status of 404 let's click
on it to see more details here we have
three sections click on General now you
can see request URL request method
status code and other data a status code
of 404 means that we don't have the
requested URL for each URL we need to
have an HTTP route the default HTTP
route of the server is a slash and you
can see the message of cannot get a
slash so let's make it in index.js we
use Express framework to create our HTTP
Roots I want to create a new road for a
slash Road I use app.get the get is our
HTTP method that generally used for
getting a resource from server we have
some other HTTP methods and we will work
with them later the first parameter of
get is an estring for our row so let's
use a slash the second parameter is on
callback function that handles this
request in this callback function we
receive request and response and we can
manage both of them for example we can
unlock the request and also we can
return any message with our response
also we can send an HTTP status code for
example let's send 234 with any message
you want and now let's check the browser
okay
well we have our message and also our
status code is 2 3 4.
now let's add a mongodb database to our
project you can use a local database or
an online database in this tutorial I
want to use a free online database let's
open mongodb.com website
and in this website click on the sign in
button here you can sign up if you don't
have any accounts I already created an
account here so I choose Google
authentication to sign in
here click build the database
in first row we see the options I choose
free and zero plan I don't change
provider and region it is not important
in this tutorial next I choose a name
for my database like Books store map tag
is optional so I don't use it and
actually create
here we choose the authentication with
username and password I use a simple
route for username and a root for
password but don't forget to always have
a strong password for your database and
this is a local project I don't add any
IP for this database then click finish
and close
here you can see list of your databases
let's click on connect button to get
connection string here click on drivers
and here on first section select the
last version of node.js on the third
section copy this connection string we
need to use it on our server so let's go
to config.js and create a new variable
for it and paste it here and you need to
add your password here and also you can
choose a collection name so here let's
add a books collection please create a
free database for yourself this database
will be deleted after tutorial now let's
go to index.js and use it I import it
from config.js
and for working with mongodb database we
need one Goose Library let's install it
using npmi mongoose
then import it into our file we can use
Mongoose that connect to connect
database and add a URL as a parameter to
it then we can have that then that cache
structure to handle different situations
of success and failure on Cache I simply
receive the error and log it to the
console and and then first I login
success message to console
also I want my Express server to run
only if database connection is
successful so I simply cut my app.listen
method and paste it inside of this block
now let's run our server by npm run
there and check the console if we see
two success messages it means that we
are okay and both database and server
are running
now we have mongodb database and
Mongoose Library Mongoose is a popular
object data monitoring library for
mongodb it allows us to interact with
mongodb easily which our script commands
let's have a quick look at
mongoosejs.com here we see a simple
example of using Mongoose in this
example we want to save a cat to
database we need a model for cat and
this cat must have a schema for example
a name with type of a string then we use
that model to interact with database
let's copy this chat model and go to our
project and create our book model
creating a model in index.js is not a
good idea it is better to always have a
folder structure let's create a new
folder named models in this folder we
keep all our project models first I
paste the cat model here I change its
name to book then I use export keywords
so that I can use it in another file for
a schema this book just has a name but
what if you want to have other fields
the better approach is to create a
schema outside and use it here we have a
schema method of mongoose that can help
us so let's create a book schema
variable and it equals to Mongoose that
schema and inside of that and we can
have an object of fields and each object
can have some options first I want title
with type of string and I want it to be
required so I use required true let's
copy paste it and have an author again
with type string and require it off two
again paste and have a publisher feed
this field has type of number
and this is it we don't need ID because
ID will be handled automatically by
database and you will see this we can
have some other fields for timestamps
like time of creation and time of last
update in order to having them after
Fields object let's have another object
and add time stamps true and that's it
now let's use this book schema for our
model the book model is now ready to use
well now we have a book model and it's
time to create our first book first
let's import book model from its folder
for creating and saving a new book we
need a new HTTP route we type of post
post method usually is used to create a
new resource then let's use express app
and create app.post the first parameter
is wrote so I use a slash books the
second parameter is a callback function
this function receives request and
response and handled
because working with Mongoose is an
asynchronous process we can use async
keyboard for our callback function I
also use a try catch blog for handling
success and failure in catch below I
simply receive the error then I log that
arrow to the server console then I
return a response with a status of 500
and I send an object read error message
in try blog first let's have a quick
validation for our input which comes
from request.body so I check all of
required fields to be in requested body
and if they are not I return a response
with a status of 400 and I send a
message for client then let's create a
variable for new book and use our
request body for title author and
publisher then let's call book.create
and send this for new book to it and
save the result to a book variable and
finally I return a status quo of 201 and
send a book to the client now let's
start project with npm run Dev and test
it for testing a post method we cannot
use browser so I use Postman it is a
good tool for working with web apis to
create a new book with Postman let's
open a new request first choose HTTP
method which is post then paste your url
here my URL is a slash book so it would
be HTTP localhost your Port slash books
then we need to send the body to our
road let's choose raw here and here
choose Json and then send your data as a
Json to our server I use some test data
and then I click send button well we
have an error because the body is not
recognizing our server so let's go back
to the index.js again and add a
middleware for parsing our request body
we can use express.json and it will
allow the experts to use Json body now
let's go back to postman and test again
I send my data again and this time you
can see that book is created and I have
the status of 201 and the created book
also in this book you can see that I
have underline ID and timestamps
well we created a book and it saved on
database successfully now let's create a
new row to get all books from database
we use app.get because this is a get
method the router of this method is
again a slash books but it is different
from previous roads that was a post
method and this is a get method and they
are different
again let's have an async callback
function to handle our request and on
catch I receive the error log into the
server console and then I return a
response with a status of 500 and the
error message then in try block I use
book.find and pass it an empty object to
get list of all books from database and
save it in a books variable then we can
return a status of 200 and send books to
the client let's go to the postman and
check it so let's create a new request
and choose get for our method and type
the URL I use the previous URL with the
slash books and then click the send
button to see the result
then we receive the list of books as an
array and the status is 200. that's good
but let's have a better output for this
route so I want to have a shape for this
output let's go back to its rows and
instead of sending just the books Let's
create a new object and in this object I
want to send two values account that
would be books that land and the data
that would be our books now let's go
back to postman anthesis again
and that's it you can see that no I have
a better structure for my data
we created an HTTP route for getting all
books but let's say we want to have
another road to see details of a single
book as another example if you have a
list of products you may want to show
the product details to the client you
can send the idea of that product to the
server and ask for the details let's do
this because this method is like get all
books I simply copy and paste this
method and edit it well this photo is
for getting one book from database by ID
the method is again yet but in road we
need to receive an ID in order to tag
and parameter in roads to use colon so
the road would be books slash colon ID
and we need this ID to search in
database so let's de-estruction it from
request.parents then use book.find by ID
and send this ID and the name of return
will be book and we return this book to
the client now let's check it in Postman
let's create a new request and use get
for its method
the first part of URL is same as the
books list but we need an ID so let's
copy an ID from the books list and paste
it in the URL and then send our request
well it is working and we receive the
requested book
now it's time to update a book well
update is a little tricky because we
need both requested params and request
that body in fact we need an ID panel to
find the book in the database then we
need request that body to update it so
let's implement it we need a new route
for updated boot this time we need to
use after output because we use put
method to update a resource so the road
must be a slash books a slash colon ID
and we have an async callback function
with a try catch again in Cache we
receive the error and first log it to
the server console then return a
response with the surface of 500 and
error message in try block first let's
have an validation we check title author
and publisher and if one of them are
missing the return and response with the
status of 400 and a message then with
this structure the idfirm
request.parents this time I don't create
a new variable like HTTP post method of
create a book I use book Dot find my ID
and update and pass ideas first
parameter and request that body as
second parameter and I save the result
in a variable then we can check the
result if the result is false we return
a status of 404 with a message else we
return a status of 200 with a message
I use any message you want no let's go
to the postman and test it
I create a new request the request
method is put the URL is book slash ID
so let's copy one book ID
10 minute body we previously sent a body
on creating a book so now you are
familiar with it I put some random data
here and then I press send and if you
see our success message it means that
everything works fine and you can simply
go and check that book to see if it is
updated or not and also Let's test an
invalid idea and check the result again
so with invalid ID we'll receive 404 of
it it's message
now let's delete a book fourth editing a
book we just need its ID and we don't
need body so let's implement it we need
a new route for deleting a book fourth
method we use after delete delete method
is the standard HTTP method to delete a
resource for road we use a slash books a
slash colon ID again we have an async
callback function and then try catch
blocks in Cache we'll receive the error
first I log into the server console then
I return a response with a status of 500
and error message now let's go to the
tribe like
ID structure the ID from request that
params then I use book dot find by ID
and delete and passbook ID to it and I
say the result in a variable name result
then I check the result if the result is
false I return a status of 404 with an
error message else I return a status of
200 with a success message you can use
any message as you wish now let's go to
the postman and test our new HTTP route
I must create a new request the request
method is delete the URL is again like
the update so let's copy one book ID and
use it here
and I don't need body so I simply click
Send to see the result and if you see
our success message it means that
everything works fine and our book
deleted successfully
well we created our HTTP roads now let's
refactor them to have a better
application our application is okay but
what if we have more than one model
let's say we have eight models and for
each model you need five rows then we
must create 40 HTTP rows in index.js is
it good no this is not a good solution
we always try to use code disability and
folder structures like what we did for
our models in this situation we can use
express router let's do this first let's
cut all of our HTTP roads that handle
books
then we must create a new folder named
routes
inside that we created a file for each
model let's create books route for now
and I paste the HTTP roads and minimize
them all to see them better in this file
we need Express router so let's import
Express from Express then I Define a
variable named router to be expressed
router then instead of app you can use
this router so let's change all of the
apps with router and finally I export
this router as a default export
also we are using book model so let's
import book in this file
next step is to use them in index.js as
a middleware so let's go to index.js and
import book clouds from its Road
then we use a middleware for a slash
books and we can pass books route to it
this will say experience that for each
request with prefix of ports handle them
with this middleware and because of this
we must change our roads so let's go
back to books road again here the slash
books are redundant and we don't need
them so let's delete them to be able to
work with our middleware
now let's go to postman and check our
server again
I send the request to get books list and
you can see that everything is working
and they are okay so I will refactor is
working correctly
well we refactored our server and it is
working fine we tested our HTTP routes
with Postman and they are working now
let's talk about one of the most
important topics in web development
course policy in order to have a better
understand of it first let's see it in a
real world example on Postman and react
project
in Postman I send a request to the
server and I received the response
without any problem that's good now
let's check it in a react project
I created a simple react project and
here you can see that I'm sending a
simple request to our server to get the
list of books and then log it on the
server console let's go to the browser
and check it here I open developer tools
and console tab then I refresh my page
to see a new request now you can see
this error access to XML HTTP request
adds this address from origin of
localhost 3000 has been blocked by
course policy no access control allow
origin header is present under requested
resource well this is the course policy
error course stands for cross origin
resource sharing course is a security
mechanism in the browsers that restricts
the ability of a web page to make
requests to a different domain in fact
course policy is a web security
mechanism that prevents unauthorized
cross-origin access to a resource or a
server when a web page makes a request
to a different domain the browser sends
a request to the Target server the
server will check that whether the
request is permitted or not server can
check Origins methods and headers and
allow or deny the request and this is
what happened in our react example but
how we can fix it well it is too easy in
node.js let's go back to our server and
handle course policy to handle course
error you need to install a new package
let's open our terminal and type in PMI
course after that I import course in
index.js and it must be used as a
middleware we have two different options
to use it first we can use just course
with parentheses in this way we have a
default value of a star that allows
everything now let's go back to browser
and test it I refresh my page and wait
for the result and you can see that I'm
receiving a response from server without
any error good let's go back to server
and test another option second option is
to allow custom Origins this is a better
way because we have more control over it
for this we can use an object in course
in this object we can use origin methods
and allowed headers so for origin we can
use HTTP localhost 3000 for methods we
can use get post put and delete for
allowed headers we can use content type
and that's it no only the clients with
this origin can access our server let's
go back to browser and check it again
well again we have access to our server
without any course error
well we created our server now it's time
to create our front-end project with
react there are different solutions to
create a new react project a lot of
tutorials use CRA or create a package
and it is not bad but we have a better
solution with wheat is a build tool that
works better than CRA let's use it and
create a new react project using the
export terminal first delete this
front-end folder it was just for showing
that we have another project now make
sure that you are on Main folder and
type npm create Veet at latest if you
don't have latest version of wheat it
would ask you to install it then you
need to type your project name for
example floor 10 then select react
then select JavaScript and that's it
your new react project is ready now
change your directory by this command CD
front-end then type npmi to install npn
package
after that let's add failing CSS to our
project
opentylink website and go to get started
then on framework guide choose Veet we
have done a step one already so let's go
to step 2 copy this command and run it
in your terminal npm install Dash
detailing CSS for CSS Auto prefixer
after that copy the next command and run
it NP styling CSS init dashboard this
command creates two files for you
tailing config and post CSS config then
copy this content and paste it in table
and config then copy these three lines
go to index.css and delete everything
and paste them then delete app.css
because we don't need it anymore then go
to app.js6 and delete everything and
create a new component using rafc I'm
using an extension name es7 plus let me
show you that this extension allows me
to use rafc to create new components now
let's use some saving classes to make
sure our codes are fine for example PG
rate of 400 and text white now let's run
our project using npm run Dev to see it
well it seems that everything works fine
now we have a ready to use react project
with daily CSS
now we have our react project we want to
have a single page application or Spa so
our application would not be refreshed
on Page Changing we don't have this
functionality in react itself so we need
to install a new package let's open
Terminal and make sure to be on
front-end project and type npm I react
router then we need some configuration
for it let's go to main.jss here we need
to import from reactor to the Dom the
browser router then use it and pass the
app components to it as children
that's it now we have access to react
router now on all of our project now
let's go to app.j6 here first important
react rotate them two things roads and
routes then in return section of our
component we return these routes inside
of it we can have different routes for
each road we need path and element so
let's create five rows for five
different pages and I'll create this
space to use them here create a new
folder in SRC and name it as page and
inside of that let's create five
different components and use them as our
application base one createbook.jsys
to deletebook.jsies
three edit book.jsx
for home.j6 and 5 Showbox at j6
that's it now let's go back to after GSX
and first we need to import them one by
one so let's import home create watch
show watch edit book delete book now
let's use them in our rows a slash goes
to home component a slash books slash
create goes to create book component a
slash books slash details slash colon ID
goes to show movie a slash boobs slash
edit slash colon ID goes to edit book
and slash books slash delete colon ID
goes to delete book and that's it so we
test them one by one when we develop
space
now we have all of our roads let's
continue I want to use two npm package
so let's go to terminal and start them
npmi IX use react icons we use axios for
sending HTTP requests and we use react
icons for its icons then let's run our
server so type CD backend and then npm
run div then uncomment the default
course middleware and comment the second
one because our IP is different in this
project now let's open a new terminal
for our front-end project type CD
front-end and then npm round div
before developing our home page I want
to create a component for loading estate
this is a good idea to show our user as
spinner when it is a loading estate
let's create a new folder called
components and create a new file named
spinner.js6
and inside of that let's have a division
with class names of animating width of
16 height of 16 margin 8 rounded full
and bgs skyr 600 that's it now let's go
to home page and implement it let's
import use this data and use effect from
react then we import axios from axios
then import a spinner from its address
and then we need a link of drag router
down then we need some icons like AI
outline edit BS info Circle and the
outline add box and in the outline
delete
then we want to have two different
states so let's create them one state
for our books with default value of an
empty array then a loading HD default
value or false then we need us effect to
call our backend I don't talk about user
State and use effect because I assume
that you are familiar with basic react
let's create a user effect with an empty
dependency array in that first let's use
set loading to true then call access.get
with our backend Road for books list
then we receive response and set books
to
response.data.data and then set loading
two files response.data is the object of
our response result and in that we had
content data so we use this data to save
it on our state on Cache block we
receive error and then we log it to the
console and then we set loading
yesterday to false now let's work on j6
parts
in main division we use P4 or padding 4.
then let's have a division with class
names of flags justify between items of
Center then let's have an H1 with class
names of text 3x large margin y of 8 and
textile books list
after this H1 let's have a link to a
slash box slash create and for this
label we use an icon up in the outline
ad box with classes of text sk800 and
text Forex large after the first
division let's open a curly brace and
check if you are unloading a state or
not and if it is true let's render a
spinner component else we return a table
with classes of with full border
separate and Border spacing two in that
we must have a t head and a t-body in
t-head let's have a tiro and in that I
want to have a 3D with classes of Border
or the estate 600 rounded MD and fixed
off no then let's have another THB same
classes and text of title then again
another th we takes out author but with
an additional class of Max MDA hidden so
that this column would be hidden in
Mobile and tablet sizes and again
another th with same classes with title
of publisher
finally let's have a thp title of
operations but for this one I don't use
Maxim V of hidden so we have five
columns and two of them would be hidden
four lower sizes
then let's open a curly brace and use
books.map with an arrow function we
receive book an index for each item of
books array and we return a TR with key
of book dot underline ID and class name
are height 8. first item is a TD bit
class names of border border estate 700
rounded MDR take Center and for its text
we open equilibriage to use index plus
one because index starts from zero but
we need to start from one then let's
have another TD bits and classes and
text of book title then another TD the
title of book dot author but for this
one we use max mdl hidden like the top
section then let's have another tdv
book.publish here and again with Max and
you have hidden and finally another TD
for our operations in the final TD I use
a division with class names of flags
justify Center Gap xr4 and in this
Division I want to have three different
links with icons let's create a link to
a slash box a slash details slash book
dot underline eye I'm using the syntax
to create Dynamic roads inside this link
let's have a bscilling for with classes
of text weeks large text screening 800.
then another link to a slash books a
slash edit slash book dot underline ID
with edit icon and yellow color then
find a link to a slash books a slash
delete book dot underline ID with delete
icon and a red color now let's format
our document and then go to our
application to see the result
first let's just add
then let's test book details then let's
test book edit
then test book delete and you can see
that they are all working fine
after showing all books in the table we
can show one book details in another
page before that I want to create a
reusable component for my back button I
want to have a button to go back to our
books list let's create it first in
components folder let's create a new
file name back button.j6 inside of that
first import link from recruiter down
then import vs Arrow left from dragged
icons we can receive a destination prop
here with default value of a slash so if
we don't pass it the destination will be
a slash Road by default for main class I
use flex and inside of that let's create
a link component to destination and for
class names I use bgs Sky 800 text white
adding xr4 padding wire one rounded up
LG and Vita fit inside the link we can
use our icon with class name of text
tweaks large and that's it now I go to
showboat component first let's close the
Explorer to have some more space
then we need to import use effect and
use a state from react then we need
axios also we need to use params from
regulator down and also we need back
button component and the spinal
component in our show book we need book
estate for handling our book show then I
use a loading state to handle the
loading time then idea structure ID from
use params then I use the use effect
hook and in that first I set loading to
true then we use axios.get with the
address of this book with its ID then I
receive response and I set response data
to book a state then I set load into
files and in catch block I receive error
and I simply lock that error and then I
set load into false in return section I
use a padding for class 4 main div then
I use back button and it has default row
so we don't need to pass row to it then
let's have an H1 with glasses of text 3x
large margin by 4 and value of show book
then let's check loading estate if it's
true we can show a spinal component else
we can show a division with classes of
flags Flex column border 2 border Sky
400 rounded its large Vita feed and
padding of four then I want to use a
structure and repeat it let's create it
I use the division with classes of
margin y4 inside that I use a standard
class names of take six large margin
writer 4 takes layer 500 and the value
of ID then I use another expanded value
of book dot underline ID the other parts
are copy paste so let's copy it and use
title and book the title then another
copy with author and book dot author
again another copy we publish here and
book.publish here and next item is
create time and new data of
book.ql.2s3 and final one is a copy with
last update time and new data of
book.updated at dot twist stream and
that's it now let's go to our
application and test it
and here I test some of my books and you
can see that it is working correctly
now let's work on creating a new book in
createbook.j6 we need to import user
State then we need back button a spinner
axios and use navigate from regular
there are different solutions for
controlling our form data I simply use
three different states for them so let's
use title author and publisher then I
use a loading state after that I use
navigate equals to use Navigator I need
this to navigate to Main Road after
creating our new book then I create a
handle Save Book function for handling
our book create operation here first
let's make a new data object with value
of title author and publisher then I set
loading to true then I use access.pose
to a slash books and I send data as
second parameter and then block I simply
start loading to files and navigate to a
slash Road
and on catch block I received error and
I settled into files then show an alert
with some text and then lock the error
to console then let's work on js6 for
main div let's add class time of padding
4. then I add back button component here
then let's have an H1 with class names
of text 3 is large margin y of 4 and
value of create book then let's check
the loading estate and if it is true we
show a spinner else to show an empty
string then let's have a division with
classes of flags Flex column border 2
border Sky 400 rounded its large width
of 600 pixel padding of 4 and marginally
sub Auto then I want to have a structure
and repeat it so let's create a division
with class name of margin y4 inside that
I want to have a label with class names
of text 6 large margin rate of 4 takes
layer of 500 and value of title then
let's have an input with type of takes
value of title and change we received
event and set title to
event.target.value and class names of
Border 2 border gray 500 padding X of 4
padding by of 2 vita food then we can
simply copy and paste this structure for
label let's use author then change the
value to Auto and change the unchanged
to set author then let's copy paste this
structure again and use publish here for
label as well as value and for on change
we use set publish here finally let's
have a button with classes of padding 2
bgs5 300 and margin of 8 and on click we
call under say book function and you
save for its label now let's go to our
application and test it here let's
insert some information for our new book
and after that we press save and wait
for the result if it is successful we
will be redirected automatically to the
home page and as you can see our new
book here
now we can work on edit food because the
structure of our edit is like create
either to createbook.js6 and copy
everything then I go back to edit book
and paste all of them instead of current
component then I change the name of our
component to edit book again and I
export default edit work then let's go
to the H1 and change it from create book
to edit book and in edit we first fetch
our book with its ID from backend and we
need to use effect and use product for
this purpose so let's go to the top of
our page and import use effect and use
params then we can simply restructure
the ID from use params then let's use
use effect and inside of it first set
loading to true then call
axios.getrotub slash books slash ID then
click on receive data and set auto to
response.data that other set publisher
to response the data.publish here and
the title of
response.data.title and then set loading
to files and on catch below we can
simply set load into files show an alert
with the custom text and then log the
arrow to the console now we have our
book data in estate so we must be able
to see it on Imports let's go to the
application and check it before continue
well it seems that it is working so
let's continue
the only change here is the handle Save
Book function let's rename this function
to handle edit book again we want data
and set loading but for HTTP method we
need put also we need the idea of book
so I use template literals and I add ID
after slash books and the other
functionality is the same so we don't
need to change them but we change the
function name so let's go to the button
add on on click section change the name
to handle edit work now let's go to our
application and test it
let's click on edit button on one random
book we need to wait for the loading
State and then we can see the book data
let's edit them to some random data and
then click save the application goes to
the Loading and after loading in
successful response we must be
redirected to home page and here we must
see our updated data
and the final page of our main stack
project is delete book so let's work on
it in this book.js6 we need to import
user State back button a spinner axios
use navigate and use param from drag
router then let's have a loading state
after that I use navigate equals to use
navigate then IDs structure ID from use
power arms then I create a handle delete
book function here first I set load into
true then I use axios.delete to slash
books idea of our book and then blog I
simply set loading to files and navigate
to a slash Road on catch block I
received error and I settled into files
then show an alert with some text and
then lock the error to the console in
return section for main division I use
last name of padding 4 then I use back
button after that I use an H1 tag with
classes of text 3 is large margin by a 4
and takes off delete push then let's
check loading estate and if it's true we
return a spinal component else we return
an empty S3 then let's have a division
with last names of flags Flex column
item Center border 2 border scale of 400
rounded x large width of 600 pixel
padding of a and margining sub Auto then
let's have an H3 with class name of text
2 weeks large and takes up are you sure
you want to delete this book then let's
have a button with class name of padding
4 busy rate of 600 takes wide margin of
8 and Vita of full and on click we
invoke handle delete book function and
for its labeled use yes delete it and
that's it let's go to our application
and test it
and here we can click on delete button
of any book we want indeed page we can
click on the delete button and after
successful delete we must be redirected
to a home page and here you can see that
the book is deleted
well our Cloud application is completed
no let's make it more beautiful and
elegant I want to have two different
options to show the book's list to
viewers table and cards we implemented
the table so let's add cards in First
Step let's go to components folder and
create a new folder named home in that I
create two components bookscard.jsx
j6
first we need to refactor the table so
let's go to home page and first let's
import books table and bootcard then cut
the table tag from this page and go to
books table and paste it inside of
return section we need books list so we
receive it from props also we are using
link and some icons so let's copy the
link and the icons from home page
and paste them here and no it is
completed in order to use it in home
page instead of all table tag we use
this component and we pass books to it
after refactoring the table we need a
state to control the type of show so
let's add a shorter State and use a
default value of tables for it then
right after the main div let's create
another division with class name of flex
justify center items of Center and get
itself for then I use a button with
class name of bgs5300 and however pgs5
of 600 padding xr4 padding wire 1 and
rounded up LG and on click I said so
type to table and I use table for its
text then we can copy this button and
reuse the classes and unclick this
sensual type 2 card and I use card for
its text now we have the functionality
of changing the design and let's go down
and change the return after loading so
after loading we check that if show type
equals to table we return box table else
we return books car
and the passbooks to it now let's check
the result until knowing the application
after loading we can see the table and
if I choose cards we can see the cards
component so let's go and complete it
here we need to import link from reactor
down then we need to import Pi book open
text slide and we are user Circle AI
outline edit and this info Circle and
and the outline delete then I received
the books as props
for my individual let's use class names
of grid and SM grade Columns of 2 on LG
grid Columns of 3 and an Excel give it
Columns of four so it would be
responsive based on the screen size then
we need to use bookstart map and receive
the item and return a division with key
of item that underline ID and class
names are border 2 border gray of 500
run the large padding xr4 padding by of
2 margin of 4 relative and on however we
have Shadow of its large
instead of that first let's use an H2
tag with class names of absolute top one
right of two padding X of 4 padding y of
1 BG rate of 300 and rounded up LG and
for the text we can use item.publisher
then let's have an H4 with class names
of margin y of 2 takes area of 500 and
we can use item.underline ID Inside Out
is H4 then let's have a division with
class name of flags justify a start
align items of Center and GAP X of 2 and
inside of that let's use Pi book open
text slide and for the class names let's
use text rate 300 and text off 2x large
then we can have an H2 with class name
of margin y of 1 and we use item.title
for its label
after that I want to have another
division with class names of flags
justify a start items of Center and GAP
X of 2 and I use an icon of via user
circle with class names of text red 300
and it takes two weeks large then I use
an h2b class name of margin volume 1 and
I use item.atel for its text then I want
to have another division for the button
so let's create a new division with
class 9 of flags justify between items
of Center Gap X of 2 margin top of 4 and
padding R4 inside of that I want to have
three links for the first one I want to
have a link to a slash books slash
details slash item.id and for the icon I
use BS info circle with class names of
text to x large text building up 800 and
on however I use text black then I want
to add another link to a slash books
slash edit slash item that under ID and
I use AI outline edit again with class
names of text to is large takes yellow
of 600 and on however I want to have
takes off black and for the last link
let's use a link to a slash books slash
delete slash item.under ID and use an
icon of MD alt like delete with class
names of text tweaks large takes a red
600 and however we want to have text
black now let's go back to our
application and test it
and here after loading we can choose
table and we can see the table view of
our books and also we can use card and
we can see the cards view of our books
in previous lesson we implemented book
scar component now let's make it better
in this components we are mapping over
the books array and we return a division
for each item and we use it as a single
book card but a better approach is to
make this division a reusable components
so that we can use it in any other
components we want and also it is easier
to maintain refactor and also change so
let's cut all of the division inside of
the map and in components folder on home
let's create a new component then book
single carta.js6
and paste the division in return section
this is a separate component so we
received a book object as a prop and we
change all of the item usage to book
after that we need to have the link and
the icons so let's copy all of them from
books car
and paste them here no this is a
reusable component and it just need a
book crop let's go back to books card
here first I import the new component
then in map section I return the book
single card component and I pass key of
items that underline ID tweet and also I
pass a book equals to item prop to it
and that's it no it must work let's go
to the application and test it
here after refresh everything must work
fine and also open the console and check
that you don't have any error here in
console
now let's add another feature to our
project I want to have a model to show
some information for each book in
components home let's create a new file
name bookmodel.jsx
and inside of that first let's import AI
outline clone Pi book open text slide
and Via user Circle phone react icons
then let's define some props so we need
Bush and on close we use this book to
show some data and use unclose to close
the model then for main division let's
use these classes fixed Digi black vgo
opacity 60 top of 0 left of 0 right of
zero bottom of zero Z index of 50 Flex
justify of Center and items of Center
and for unclick we invoke on closed prop
this is the container of our model it is
a fixed division that would be on the
top of everything and we added Z index
of 15 to be sure about this inside of
that let's have another division for
unclick we receive event and we call
event.stop propagation and for class
names we use width of 600 pixel maximum
width of full height of 400 pixel these
are white rounded up it's large padding
of four Flags Flex column and position
of relative we use a stock propagation
so that with each click the parent and
click would not be invoked because we
need this model to be closed only in two
conditions first click outside of the
model white area and second click on the
red close button of the model void area
that will Implement soon now we have our
model and we can show anything we want
just for the close button I use AIO Auto
and close icon with the last names of
absolute write-off 6 top of 6 takes off
3x large takes rate of 600 and cursor
off pointer and until I call and close
props so this button will close our
model then let's copy some of the single
bootcard elements here to show to the
viewer you can choose anything you want
and for the first H2 which is published
here I delete these classes absolute top
one Android 2 and I use Vita fit and
after them I use two optional paragraphs
you can use them or you can ignore them
and these are just four demonstrations
now our model is completed and it's time
to use it let's go to book single cards
and first we need to import bi show then
we import user State and book model then
we need a new estate name show model
with default value of files this state
would control the open and close the
state of our model
no on links division let's add a bi show
with class names of text 3x large takes
up below of 800 and however let's have a
tick stop black and the cursor off
pointer and ankylic we call such show
model with value of true this is for
showing our model
and before the last division of this
component let's open a curly race to
access JavaScript and check if show
model is true then we run the book model
and we pass the book to it for on kilos
we call Central model with value of
files and that's it now let's go to the
application and check the result
and here for cards view we can see the
icon of model and by clicking leads we
can open the model and see the data and
you can see that if I click inside of
the white area the model is still open
but clicking on close button will close
the model also clicking all side of
model area will also close the model
well our bookstore project has full
Cloud functionality but we can make it
even better when we alter our database
we create update or delete we redirect
our user to home page if the operation
is successful but we don't give any
feedback and the user can't see any
details about the operations and this is
not good for our user experience a good
approach is to show a beautiful alert to
user we can use default browser alert
but it is not beautiful I want to use a
npm package name not here stack in the
naughty stack npm page you can see how
to install and use it based on the
document and female strap app component
inside of a snack web provider to have
access to the hook cortex so let's go to
the project and use it first we need to
have a terminal on front-end directory
and we type npmi note your stack
then let's go to main.js6 and here we
import a snack bar Provider from Naughty
stack then we use it so that we have
access to it on all of our projects now
let's use it first let's go to the
createbook.js6 and here on the top
section first we need to import use a
snack bar from Nokia stack then with the
structure and create a snack bar from
use a snack bar
then on hand the say book function
before navigating to a slash row we can
call it for example I can call it as
inquiry snack bar with a message like
who created successfully and we can pass
some options like variant or success
also on catch below we can use another
example for example in queue a snack bar
of error with variant of Arrow and
that's it so we show a beautiful alert
instead of ugly browser default colors
and that's it then let's go to
editbook.js6 and do the same first we
need to import use a snack bar from not
your stack then with the structure and
create a snack bar from user snack bar
and then unhandle edit book function
before navigating to a slash road we can
call it as and create a snack bar with
message of book edited successfully and
variants of success and also on catch
below we can use increase snack bar with
message of error and variant of error
and after that I want to use it for
deleting a book operation so let's go to
the deletebook.js6 and here first we
import use a stack bar from notice tag
and then with this structure and create
a snack bar from use a snack bar and
after that on handle delete book
function before navigating to a slash
row I call it as increase snack bar of
book deleted successfully with variant
of success and also I call it on catch
below like this and create a snack bar
with message of error and variant of
error now we have beautiful feedback for
creating a book updating a book and also
deleting a book let's go to our
application and test it
first let's create a new book after
operation we can see beautiful green
alerts with message of book created
successfully and will be redirected to
home page now let's edit a book and
change it and after operation we can see
green alerts we takes off book edited
successfully and we will be redirected
to home page and finally Let's test
delete book again after operation we
must see green alerts it takes off book
deleted successfully and we must be
redirected to home page and now our
application has a better user experience
well this is the final lesson of our
book history project I hope you enjoy it
let me know if it was useful or not and
comments have a good time and goodbye